الاولى من الصباح الان لهم في حاله جيده
طبعا التنسيق مع مبنى الولايه وايضا
البلديات والى الاحمر وافاد هناك تنسيق
كامل مع كل المؤسسات الرسميه وغير الرسميه
ايضا من اجل انقاذ المواطنين من تحت
الانقاذ الاعمال المستمره كما ذكرت قبل
قليل علينا ان نتقدم بمساعدتنا
للفرق هذا وان نسهل كل الطرق
التي تساعد فرق
الانقاذنا مره اخرى ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل
للجرحى
نعمل الا نعيش هذه الكوارث مره اخرى شكرا
جزيلا
ام علي الوزير هل لديكم اي معلومات عن
المدن الاخرى كيف هو الحال فيها حاليا كما
تعلمون
هناك تنسيق شامل مع الوزراء الاخرين وايضا
مع
السيده فؤاد الذي هو الان يدير شؤون
التنسيق
لفرق الانقاذ وايضا التنسيق حول
مناطق الانقاذ في المدن العشره
فاعملنا مستمره اعمال البحث مستمره
والانقاذ مستمره انا مسؤول عن مدينه
تيربكر حاليا الوزراء الاخرين المعنيين
يتابعون كل التطورات